あっ！はっ
眠い
もう
手遅れかもしれません
こんにちは はじめしゃちょーです
皆さん５月に入りましたね
５月病ご存知でしょうか
今 リプを送ってくださったかたも
５月１日のもうお昼前の時点で
眠いと言っております
もう遅いかもしれません
５月病って皆さん聞いたことがあると思うんですけども
具体的にどんなものなのかっていうことを
ちゃんと知らないと思うんですよ
今回ちょっと５月病についてちょっと話してみようと思います
そもそも５月病とは
まぁあれだ簡単に言うとまぁ燃え尽き症候群
みたいなところがありますね
新しい環境になってこんなかやる気満々じゃないか
でやる気満々で うらぁぁってやって
ゴールデンウィークになってしまいました
ゴールデンウィークってこう休みが長いので
ふぅーう　う゛ぅぅー
って感じで休んじゃうと燃え尽きちゃって
そのゴールデンウィーク中に
4月からがんばってきたその疲れが
一気にどさっと来て
なんかこう学校とか仕事とか行きたくねぇなと
なにもしたくねーそういうちょっと
理由が不明確な身体や心の不調を
それを５月病と言うらしいでございます
５月病放っておいたら大変危険な病気です
というわけで今日はちょっとあの僕なりに
５月病についてちょっと調べてみたので
５月病によくある症状をちょっとまとめてみました
この動画を見て少しでも５月病が怖いなと思っていただけると嬉しいです
ではどうぞ
ううぅうううぅぅぅぅぅ
ううーーーーうううぅ
うううーぅ　ぃやああーーああああ
あぁ　あっあっあっああああああ
あ゛ぁ゛ーーーーあっあっあっああーーーーー
あぁ〜あ〜あ〜あ〜あ〜〜あ〜
た）まぁこっちをどう改善していくかが
た）課題になっているので
は）う゛ぅ゛ーーー
た）まぁいいところをどうやって
は）くっそぉーうぜぇえな
は）チッくっそー
た）伸ばしていけるか
は）ぅ゛う゛あ゛あ゛ーーー
は）ん゛ん゛
だ）来月なんですけど
は）ふざけんな　おい
だ）っくしょん
（はじめ苦しむ）
だ）おい行こう　やばいって本当
だ）部長怒ってるよ
は）いやもういい
だ）本当まずいって
は）いや俺行かない
だ）行こ
は）行かないよ
だ）早く早く
だ）ほら立って立って
は）行かないよ
た）ねぇまずいまずい
だ）まずいまずい
だ）早く行こ
は）いや！いや！
だ）早く
は）いや俺はもういいから
だ）いや良くない
は）もう行きなよ
だ）怒られちゃう
は）いいよいいよ俺はいいよ
た）大人だろ
は）行かないよ
だ）早く
は）辞めるもん俺もう
だ）ダメダメ
は）辞めるよ
た）辞めない
は）辞めるよ無理だもん
だ）辞めない辞めない辞めない早く
は）しらねーよもう
だ）早く
は）いいよいいよいいよ
だ）おい行くぞ早く
は）いいよいいよ
だ）もう知らないからな
は）いいよ
は）いや行かないよいや行かないから
た）部長に怒られちゃうから
は）行かないって　いや行かない
は）俺部長知らないもん　行かないよ
だ）これとこれやっといて
は）いいえ
だ）これやっといて
は）やんないよ
だ）おい江田
だ）やれ
は）やんないよ
だ）お前ちょっと来い
だ）おいお前早く来い
は）ん〜ん
だ）江田！おい
だ）ん〜んじゃない
は）あ〜あ
だ）行くぞ
は）やんないよ
だ）あ〜あじゃない
だ）やるんだよ
た）そうだ
た）ハリーポッター知ってますよね先輩
た）この前会社にエマワトソンきてたじゃないですか
た）あれエマワトソン本人が言ってたんですけど
た）はじめさんに一目惚れちゃったらしいっすよ
は）おーー
た）なんすかその反応
た）エマワトソンが一目惚れですよ
は）ほーー
た）逆玉ですよ絶対付き合った方がいいですよ
は）ふぅんー
た）えっ…なに…
た）エマワトソン
た）大学で結構近いこと教えてもらってたんで
だ）なかなか難しいけどねこの仕事会社の
た）まぁそうですねでもなんか
た）たいち先輩とかが結構教えてくれているんで
は）ぅ゛う゛　う゛え゛ぇ゛
だ）いやまぁでも結構できてる方だよほんと
た）ほんとですか？
は）う゛え゛ぇ゛
まま）はじめ起きなさい
は）ん〜ん
まま）はじめ起きなさい会社遅れるでしょ
まま）もう…
は）ん〜ん
まま）全く
は）ん、ん〜ん
は）うーん　う゛ーぅ
は）う゛ーう゛　ぶーぅ゛
は）ふ゛う゛ぅ゛う゛　うわあああああああああああ
は）ん〜ん
いや助けていや待って耳が耳が聞こえない
待ってやばい
助けて
誰かあああああああ